ich verfolge ja mit mit fassungsloser
faszination diesen deutschen wahlkampf
der für mich eigentlich immer ein
bisschen absurder wird man hört zu und
dann fallen widerworte und jetzt
stolpere ich einen satz gestern als ich
wirklich müde in mein büro gekommen ist
spreche über einen satz das
unvermeidlich im rauch stehen bleibt
solche lieblingspolitiker rausgehen
draufsteht hat gesagt sinngemäß lautet
müssen sich mit seinen cdu endlich von
rechts ab dass es so daneben und dann
sagte er laut habe ich dann mich
erinnern in den congstar freikommt sagte
er bekämpfe rechts da habe ich jetzt
gedacht dass viele wissen das möglich
kann denn die cdu überhaupt noch linke
überhaupt noch sozialdemokratische wer
das geht ja gar nicht mehr da müssen die
eigentlich mit der spd fusionieren und
ganz grundsätzlich meine in einer
demokratie
haben wir eine staatsform der alternativ
jede demokratie der welt hat eine linke
ratsseite und sie hat eine rechte rad
seite vom präsidenten ausgesetzt auf der
rechten seite das ist die bürgerliche
das ist die liberalen dass sie die
konservativen auf der linken seite
sitzen die grünen und die linken und
jetzt darf das offensichtlich in
deutschland gar keine rechte seite mehr
geben das müssen dann ist diese
konservativ machen müssen sie diesmal
auf dem schoß der grünen oder linken
sitzen auf den knien wohl freiberg wir
sind in deutschland im endstadium einer
sogenannt alternativlosen demokratie in
der alle links sein müssen rechts ist
verboten und das ist gefährlich ich
komme hier aus der schifffahrt und sage
wenn auf einem schiff alle nur noch
rechts sitzen rogers und wenn alle links
sitzen kennt das auch deshalb ich
plädiere hier für die wiedereinführung
einer richtigen demokratie in
deutschland mit demokratischen parteien
auf der linken seite um mit
demokratischen parteien auf der rechten
seite dann habt ihr wieder ein
ausbalanciertes politisches gebilde
nicht dieses einseitige stegner redding
aber köppel niemand muss ja in
deutschland irgendwas sein und wir haben
ja eine rechtspopulistische partei die
afd und was ralf stegner gemeint hat er
hat sich wie so häufig schlecht
ausgedrückt aber er meint damit
natürlich die frage der afg und in dem
fall der frage der abgrenzung von herrn
maßen zu rechtsradikalen da muss man
sagen dass in der letzten woche etwas
passiert was doch viele erschüttert hat
es gab einen beitrag bei spiegel tv wo
eine veranstaltung mit herrn maßen zu
sehen ist wo dann ein bekannter
nazi neonazi dorthin gekommen ist mit
einem 88 kennzeichen also dem den
alliierten für heil hitler genau und er
maßen hat sich eben nicht abgegrenzt hat
immer wieder für aufregung gesorgt und
wenn wir uns anschauen noch mal zu der
frage was darf man was kann was muss man
man muss gar nichts schauen sie sich an
es gibt auch ein herr nooke der bei der
ard sitzt den mann faschist nennen darf
und er sitzt trotzdem immer noch bei der
afg also die these zu glauben irgendwas
sei ausgeschlossen und irgendwas dürfe
nicht sein trifft ja nicht zur
beerdigung ganz korrekt also ganz kurz
ganz kurz also ich gebe ihnen absolut
recht und wenn wir hier über rechte
reden wir über bulgarische konservativer
recht so nicht über eine rechtsradikale
partei wie die fdp spielt hier nach
meiner meinung nach keine rolle aber die
konservativen in ihrer recht dasein in
sünde letzten fünf bis sieben jahren
massiv auch geschrumpft und auch mit
merkels kurs natürlich auch link links
gewandert und das schafft eine eine art
von vakuum und in diesem vakuum gibt es
keine partei die das auch heute im
großen stil vertritt maßen ist nicht die
alternative ist teil des problems und
ich suche mir ein recht konservativer
politik in deutschland die in der lage
ist themen die mich beschäftigen und
viele andere bürger auf eine sachliche
differenzierter art und weise an das
gericht in deutschland seit vielen
jahren da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht
eine sprachliche wie auch gedankliche
verluderung des umgangs mit dem begriff
recht wir geben mehr dagegen habe ich
mich immer gewehrt ich habe auch immer
wenn ich rechtsextrem meinte habe ich
rechtsextrem geschrieben und ansonsten
ist es stimme ihn völlig zu ansonsten
ist es natürlich gibt es eine ehrenhafte
demokratische rechte muss es auch geben
dann hatte man früher konservativ
genannt das ist durch angela merkel ein
bisschen durcheinander geraten gibt es
nach konservative wie definieren sie
sich das aber ein anderes thema aber der
umgang mit dem begriff rechts ist
absolut unzulässig und das sind die
einen die tun es schlampig weil sie es
nicht besser wissen und die anderen tun
es absichtsvoll weil die wollen
natürlich alles was jenseits von links
ist im weitesten sinne
tabuisieren ja dass die sind irgendwie
auf dem falschen weg und diejenigen die
ihn in die in die karten spielen ist die
afg weil bei denen alles durcheinander
gfd hat im ehrenhaften sinne rechte und
sie hat rechtsextreme
der berliner landesverband der afg nach
meiner wahrnehmung ist ein rechter der
thüringische unterröcke ist ein
rechtsextremer um nicht zu sagen
neonazistischer die habt wollen das auch
alles gerne in sich aufnehmen weil die
viele stimmen sammeln wollen die die
bringen sozusagen die geben dem noch
nahrung aber via palma journalisten
müssen wir darauf achten dass wir die
begriffe von meinen ganzen gebäude ganz
ein wichtiger punkt hinzuzufügen was ich
beobachte und das beobachte ich auch in
der schweiz ich beachten beobachten eine
zunehmende radikalisierung
und intoleranz auf der linken seite weil
die linken sind tolerant gegenüber links
aber wenn einer nicht links ist und das
zeigt eben diese stegner aussage wenn
ein recht ist und sich völlig
einverstanden nicht rechtsextrem
wichtige den stechschritt recht
überzeugend etwas sondern da ist einfach
nicht links ist rechts der mitte und die
linken und das finde ich eben gefährlich
in einer demokratie haben angefangen das
objektiv rechts insgesamt fast zu
kriminalisieren synonym zu verwenden mit
rechtsextrem was ganz etwas anderes ist
und wenig beobachtet dass ein armin
laschet in einem kanzler dreikampf sich
sozusagen glaubt von rechts wo die cdu
ja durchaus auch nicht nur ist eine
mittepartei aber durchaus auch etwas
rechts damit besteht wenn es sich davon
distanziert und abgrenzt dann zeigt mir
das einfach wie stark eigentlich diese
intolerante zur
tyrannischen verabsolutierung ihrer
eigenen standpunkt den eigenen linken
irgendwo die diskurs hoheit in
deutschland oder in den medien schon
weitgehend gewonnen hat und dadurch
lassen sich daneben die vernünftigen
konservativen und das beobachten mit
sorge in die defensive drängen und am
schluss hast du wirklich die situation
wo alles auge mich da ich bin auch
irgendwie links oder ich bin ich kommen
sie denn darauf er sich und dem man
immer sagen muss also ich meine wenn man
eine meinung vertritt und es sind einer
meinung öffentlich ist dann muss man
auch damit umgehen dass gegenwind gibt
ja natürlich wenn sie jetzt im weise
nicht wenn sie bei twitter unterwegs
sind was er wahrscheinlich ein linkes
medium ist dann müssen sie damit rechnen
aber es gibt einen unterschied zwischen
kritik die es legitim und zwischen eine
art von diffamierung da für diese beiden
männer auf und beiden seiten also wenn
jemand etwas sagt was die linke nicht
gefällt ihnen auch das rederecht einfach
auszusprechen ist keine demokratische
das ist
nur eine bemerkung ein fdp mitglied der
sich nicht vor rechtsradikaler
distanziert kann nicht alles recht
gelten sondern als recht häufig allein
das stimmt nicht da müssen sie immer
noch genau hingucken was der persönlich
denkt sagt und tut
[Musik]